[Music]
all right it is national refreshment day
tomorrow so what is more refreshing
honestly than a tall glass of lemonade
joining us this morning tarika the owner
of wow wow lemonade in henderson there
are three locations here in the valley
brand new in fact to the valley
originally from hawaii absolutely from
hawaii it makes perfect sense they love
to call us the ninth island so
great that you came here lemonade is
your
it's your thing lemonade is our thing we
also have cold brew coffees we have
smoothies we have acai
okay so we'll talk about these that's
the food but refreshing let's talk about
lemonade i mean that's the bread and
butter what kind of lemonade do you have
we have a lot of options of lemonades
but today we made our watermelon basil
lemonade so we're refreshing so it's our
classic lemonade we have watermelon and
then we have actual fresh basil that we
add to it
also we're gonna do a
actual um mango okay let's see mango
colada
so the mango colada um is our lemonade
we have our pressed coconut um and then
we're gonna float it with
some fresh mango puree oh great so this
is all i mean we're talking fresh as
fresh can be
kind of what you would get if you were
in hawaii right absolutely right off the
trees
it's just like in hawaii it reminds them
and so
they're super excited that we're here
to bring a little bit of hawaii too and
so that's that that's the mango mango oh
my gosh
now when you when you walk into the
store i love these these are glasses are
these something that you can purchase as
well is it part of absolutely something
that you can purchase
and then we're super big on
sustainability for wow wow so we
definitely want to leave the environment
better than what we found it um so you
purchase this beautiful mason jar and
you bring it into the stand and you're
able to get oh you've got a discount and
you can put lemonades cold brew coffees
teas smoothies you can add whatever you
like that's great
so that's our real colorada mango colada
look at that oh my gosh absolutely next
we're going to do a watermelon colada oh
okay who doesn't love watermelon ultra
refreshing absolutely so we have our
fresh lemonade we have our pressed
coconut
and then we're going to float it
and the coconut is so hydrating with the
electrolytes yeah super nice and
refreshing for
summer days here in vegas oh yeah when
it gets hot now tarika real quick um
where are you located i know you said
henderson but where can folks find you
yeah we're in henderson so we're located
at 7 11 mark street um sweet see so
right next to the costco best buy we're
neighbors with a massage envy okay
people know where that is and there's a
couple in town and i know we're running
out of time so let me just really quick
kind of point out what we have here in
the front the acai bowl i mean that's
that's healthy right there in a cup yes
absolutely and then we have our toaster
we have our strawberry lilikoi
butter toast and we bring that in
straight from hawaii we have our chili
lime we have a couple of flatbreads
there's our almond berry flatbread and
our black lava flatbread and then our
egg and avocado toast healthy nutritious
delicious and certainly refreshing
absolutely thanks for being on the show
so much for having us go check them out
wow wow lemonade yum yum is what i am
going to say